so you're a big soda company like
Coca-Cola and you're having the time of
your life people are guzzling down more
soda than water this smart young Hostess
knows there's nothing like giving folks
what they want when it comes to
refreshment what everybody wants is a
Coke the American Consumer had become
addicted consuming nearly 50 gallons of
soda a year per person which is the
equivalent of filling up this trash can
with soda and drinking it every year but
by the early 2000s trouble was on the
horizon
the masses are starting to become more
aware that soda is actually very very
unhealthy a new government report says
those sodas and sugary drinks that we
all love so much are making the
country's obesity problem worse the
report says sugary drinks such as
non-diet sodas energy drinks sweetened
bottled waters sports drinks and fruit
drinks have been linked to weight gain a
poor quality diet and in adults type 2
diabetes major headline about your
health tonight with a question mark for
anyone who drinks sodas with that
caramel color a chemical that in some
cases has been linked to cancer in mice
the other study found that people who
drank at least two sugar sweetened soft
drinks today had a higher risk of death
from digestive diseases and those who
drank artificially sweetened drinks had
an increased risk of death from diseases
that affect the circulatory system and
both groups had an increased risk of
death from Parkinson's disease I mean
this is alarming the researchers
analyzed 10 years of data where people
gave detailed information about their
eating and drinking habits over that
decade five percent developed dementia
drinking at least one artificially
sweetened beverage a day more than
doubled the risk of dementia they
started to realize that consuming soda
led to horrible things like weight gain
diabetes tooth decay heart disease
cancer maybe even death that soda
doesn't have one single nutrient or
vitamin in there just sugar that soda
was found to be very addictive thanks to
its high sugar and caffeine content so
for the first time people started
drinking less soda this is horrible if
you want to keep Americans addicted to
your bubbly sugar water you need to find
a way to change the narrative to instill
just a tiny bit of doubt in the Public's
mind that maybe a little bit of soda
here and there isn't all that bad God
forbid people didn't drink a giant trash
can worth of soda every year but fear
not because we have a tried and true
blueprint to follow it's the same
blueprint that other unhealthy
Industries like big tobacco followed
once the meddling public started
realizing their product wasn't so
healthy
propaganda
if you want to change the masses mind on
something you've got to go to the
influencers they listen to and get them
to promote the truth you want in terms
of stuff you consume into your body the
most important influencers the masses
listen to are the scientists and doctors
scientists and doctors have this magical
Aura around them where the masses
believe every word that comes out of
their mouth as long as they're wearing a
white lab coat when in reality
scientists and doctors are human so
they're just as corruptable as you and I
are so what do you do you systematically
pay off doctors and health organizations
to get the masses to believe the idea
that hey maybe soda isn't all that bad
and it goes a little something like this
stay dangerous and this is the evil
business of soda
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
modern invention a drink that has been
around for thousands of years and that
has been a vital part of human history
is wine wine is timeless it's refined it
makes you feel fancy and every man
should know a thing or two about it the
problem is like many of you I know
nothing about wines but thankfully that
is where bright sellers comes in bright
sellers is a high-end white subscription
box that delivers great wine right to
your door that way you can learn about
wines and enjoy them without being
overwhelmed and embarrassed in the wine
aisle and the coolest part is as
personalized to you all you have to do
is take a quick quiz and they'll match
you with Once from all over the globe
according to your tastes they sent me a
box of six wines and this light fruity
one was by far my favorites Because deep
down I'm basically a white girl each
bottle comes with a wine education card
so you can learn about the origins
tasting those best pairings so you can
impress people when you're out and after
trying the wines they sent you you can
rate the wine and they'll use your input
to make your box better month after
month and right now bright sellers is
giving you guys a limited time offer of
50 off your first box of six bottles
when you click the link below that means
you can get your first six bottles of
high and white for less than ten dollars
each while supporting the channel it's
perfect for Thanksgiving or any occasion
so click the link below to get your wine
now thanks to Bright sellers for
sponsoring this video
step one so in scientific evidence comes
out that suggests that too much sugar
and soda is harmful to People's Health
simply cancel it out by paying flexible
scientists to say otherwise
have them say it's not soda's fault
you're fat it's your fault because you
don't exercise enough lack of exercise
is the cause of obesity in America not
soda and poor diet what's powerful about
this is that it's still 100 true if you
don't burn off more calories than you
consume via exercise you will get fatter
why are you blaming soda when you should
be looking in the mirror which we still
agree with on top of that look we do
have sugar-free and diet versions of our
drinks so you can't blame us for your
bad choices
step two fund a bunch of health
organizations
this is along the same lines as the last
tactic the masses believe stuff that
official sounding health organizations
say so when an organization like the
Academy of nutrition in dietetics puts
out a statement supporting moderate soda
intake instead of cutting it out
altogether people listen I mean it's the
Academy of nutrition and dietetics for
God's sake so the more Health groups you
can give money to the better it's an
investment in the long term it gives you
a trustworthy mouthpiece that people
believe in little do they know it's big
soda companies like you behind the
scenes giving these groups money to say
whatever you want
because remember we don't need to stamp
out all the negative information out
there about soda a teeny tiny bit of
Doubt is all we need because even if
there's conflicting information out
there who doesn't want to believe that
their favorite soda is actually okay and
not deadly at all you just need one
reputable looking source to justify the
masses bad behavior and you're golden
step 3 build a subtle association
between health and soda at first this
may sound impossible how am I supposed
to do that but it's actually rather
simple you just need a lot of money
money money first off sponsor everyone's
favorite sports teams plaster your logo
all over the world's biggest Arenas and
stadiums paid to be the official partner
for the biggest sports leagues and games
like the prestigious Olympics which
Coca-Cola has been a long-standing
partner of Coca-Cola also supports the
paralympic games and everything else
from soccer to football to NASCAR and
more but why stop there partner up with
beautiful famous celebrities to endorse
soda then go into the music industry the
gaming industry the movie industry all
of this subtly connects the idea of soda
with health Beauty Fitness and fame so
whenever a consumer is at the soda aisle
at the grocery store contemplating on
whether or not they should buy that
12-pack of sugary delicious soda their
tiny voice in the back of their
subconscious says Well it can't be that
bad if literally the entire modern
economy is sponsored by Coca-Cola
all of these tactics mixed together
makes the masses just comfortable enough
with soda that they keep drinking it but
don't go anywhere yet because that's
just the marketing side of things what
about the production side the
ingredients that make up our beloved
drinks how did they get Americans
guzzling down a giant trash can of soda
a year once again it was very systematic
ha
[Music]
it's the 1950s and Americans were
drinking a fair amount of soda already
but that's just not enough nope you want
them to drink even more soda the problem
is it's hard to get customers to
purchase more bottles more cans more
cups of soda when people go to a fast
food joint they only ever order one cup
of soda for themselves there's no reason
for them to buy two cups of soda for
themselves so we gotta attack it from a
different angle see getting people to
buy more of your product isn't the only
way to make more money there is another
much more cunning way to make more money
off of the same customer base
so you spark up a friendship with fast
food chains and convenience stores the
types of businesses that already sell a
lot of soda every day and you guys come
up with a little plan that will get
everyone chugging down more soda than
ever before because the more soda
swallowed means the more money you stand
to make
receive at the time fast food chains
like McDonald's or Burger King were only
offering teeny tiny little seven ounce
cups of soda to their customers that's
basically half a can of Coke in 2022 it
was absurd think about how tiny that is
think about how much money was left on
the table just because these chumps were
selling your soda in small cups you
can't get people to buy more than one
cup for themselves but you can make them
buy bigger cups bigger cups meant that
stores could sell them for a higher
price which meant the customers would
fill them up with more soda which meant
that the stores would have to buy more
soda from you it was a win-win so you
slowly started sizing up first You
released bigger bottles of soda in the
stores now people could buy anything
from the standard six and a half ounce
bottle to a king-sized 26 ounce bottle
and since there were suddenly monster
sized soda bottles all over the place
people gradually got comfortable with
the idea of drinking more soda per
sitting it was still just one bottle
after all and so for decades the largest
size of soda people could buy was your
amazing 26 ounce bottle but it was still
less than a liter we can do better than
that
enter the big gulp
it's the 1980s about 25 years since you
started your mission for getting soda
sizes bigger people have become
accustomed to drinking a lot more soda
they need it to wash down the massive
oily Burgers and Fries most fast food
chains are selling so you and 7-Eleven
decide to step it up a notch so 7-Eleven
launched the big gulp for about the same
price 7-Eleven's big golf LOL gives you
the freedom to enjoy a bigger Coke 45
more and if you prefer a Pepsi they
don't have it but 7-Eleven's big gold
gives you another kind of freedom
freedom of choice
it took things to the next level
32 ounces the big gulp allowed customers
to buy four times more soda than before
you sold four times the amount of soda
to the same customer without them
needing to buy four cups of soda but why
stop there just six years later later
they released the 44 ounce Super Pig
gulp that was already more liquid than
the average stomach can hold then a
couple years after that 7-Eleven brings
its customers the Double Gulp 64 ounces
of soda
stomachs by the way in case you don't
know this our stomachs are the size of
our fists that's really how large our
stomachs are I can fit my entire arm
and by 2006 7-Eleven released its
greatest creation yet the team gold
massive one gallon jug of soda ready for
purchase but that was just 7-Eleven the
big fast food chains weren't far behind
with their jumbo drinks your plan to
increase the average order volume worked
perfectly a few years back it would have
taken over 18 different customers to
sell a gallon of soda but now a single
person easily buys a single gallon of
soda it was beautiful and all of this
came at the cost of the health and lives
of countless people and that's none of
your business obviously people choose to
drink soda you don't force them to but
if you thought that was it oh you're so
sadly mistaken
[Music]
after World War II Coca-Cola's business
exploded but you had a problem caffeine
see at the time you had been using Cola
nuts for caffeine but they grew far away
there weren't enough of them to meet
demand and where the caffeine came from
didn't really matter caffeine was all
the same so Coca-Cola needed to find a
new source of caffeine that was cheaper
and more abundant enter tea leaves at
the time the world was going through a
tea drinking craze which meant there
were a lot of damaged broken tea leaves
that westerners didn't want to buy so
they were left rotting in warehouses and
guess what these tea leaves contained
that sweet caffeine but even leftover
tea leaves weren't enough to feed the
machine that is Coca-Cola if Coca-Cola
was gonna take over the world you were
gonna need an even more stable supply of
caffeine so that's when you enlisted the
help of a little-known company called
Monsanto and ordered them to come up
with a synthetic caffeine if you could
create a synthetic caffeine made in a
lab you would have complete control over
the supply no more dealing with pesky
Cola nut Farmers or damaged tea leaves
and Monsanto pulled through
they came back with a caffeine made from
the chemicals in coal tar and in the 40s
in part because of the war they couldn't
get supplies to various things once
again we see Coca-Cola turning to
Monsanto and saying hey Monsanto you
know you've supplied us with caffeine
Sacra and all these things can you make
synthetic caffeine and Monsanto does
they figure out a way to make synthetic
caffeine from coal tar yes actual coal
tar a byproduct of processed coal that
was what we were gonna shove down the
throats of the public and it worked no
one was gonna think to ask where the
caffeine in the drink came from as long
as it tasted good no one would bat an
eye seems logical that they're thinking
is
wait a minute consumers are never going
to ask where their caffeine comes from
look at everyone I've ever talked to no
one knows where the caffeine comes from
right and so they do switch to
synthetics and if you go to their
website it's great it says we Source our
caffeine from tea leaves so that waste
Tea Leaf story is still part of it the
coffee beans uh decaf coffee and then
appropriate sources the supply problem
was solved and customers didn't know the
difference successfully creating
artificial caffeine was the success
Monsanto needed to put them on the map
after that Monsanto had nowhere to go
butt up they went on to create so many
things that benefit Humanity like agent
orange the poison that was sprayed over
Vietnam destroying the lives of locals
and Veterans then there were pcbs then
herbicides then genetically modified
seeds then seed licensing to wear today
Monsanto practically owns the entire
world's food supply and we expose all of
it in our private documentary on
Monsanto that you can watch right now by
clicking that join button below once you
join you'll have instant access to the
Monsanto documentary plus all the other
super controversial videos we can't post
publicly like our newest one on China's
very gruesome Force organ harvesting
that is definitely our most disturbing
video yet there's a 30-day refund policy
so pause the video and click that join
button below now back to the business of
soda
in 2021 Coca-Cola spent more money on
Advertising than any other Beverage
Company in the world with a marketing
budget of over 4 billion dollars that's
222 times more than the revenue of the
Super Bowl and more than the GDP of a
bunch of small Nations it's insane I
mean Coca-Cola is already ranked as the
strongest brand in America so why spend
all this money advertising a product
that everyone already knows because even
though people don't realize it a lot of
viewers spend the rest of their day
subconsciously thinking about soda
bubbles it's all just so satisfying so
when they finally come across one at the
grocery store or at a restaurant they
order it after all soda is sold at
almost every establishment on the planet
millions of people seeing a Coca-Cola
commercial and ordering one drink can
make the company billions
even with all this marketing spend even
with all the influencing tactics the
numbers don't lie soda consumption has
been on the decline for a while now
today consumers are down to just a
measly 40 gallons of soda a year that's
only four-fifths of this giant trash can
paying off scientists and organizations
does help but like tobacco it only
delayed the inevitable culture has
changed people are cutting soda out of
their diet people are starting to look
at people who drink soda with the same
disgust as someone who smokes cigarettes
at least in America big soda knows this
but for the most part it doesn't matter
too much Coca-Cola and PepsiCo are
already in your seltzers your sports
drinks your coffee your milk your
alcohol your fruit juices and much much
more
[Music]
I remember back in the days as a little
kid I would drink literally multiple
cans of soda a day and I look back on
those days but absolute disgust do you
guys still drink soda you probably
shouldn't because it's absolutely
disgusting but yeah if you're new here
this is one of the biggest channels on
YouTube for documentaries on money power
war and crime just like this one so if
you'd like to subscribe you can follow
me on Instagram at Jake Tran but that is
going to wrap it up thanks for being
part of the watch of the end Club stay
dangerous out there and I will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
thank you